by the time he'd started this video
diary pelly illy's mom was in intensive
care
the news just got worse that has
that's positive damn so
is he going no he just has to
self-isolate for two weeks
okay
are you gonna work on that stuff yeah
we don't know what mom's status is yet
she's just
we're waiting
he was taking care of his young brother
and his worsening dad
and another brother also falling ill
just very eye-opening experience
and humbling because
[Music]
i have to do this on my own right now
and a lot of people are depending on me
and i you know i'm good with it
it just is overwhelming
days later his dad was also heading to
hospital
you what you want me to take you to
kaiser
dad you can't even make it down the
stairs i will
you can barely make it from the bathroom
in all three of the family would end up
in intensive care
they are now back home and fully
recovered
it was very surreal for me it was
definitely an emotional time
you know i i think the scariest part was
just not really knowing what was gonna
happen when she was on the ventilator
you know i didn't know what me my dad
was home at that time when she was on
the ventilator and we both didn't know
if she was gonna make it at that time
and they've learned their samoan
heritage is part of the story
in los angeles where cases are surging
pacific islanders have by far the
highest infection rate of any community
often low income little access to health
care and a tradition of
staying close for our community as well
um it's a lot of um they're embarrassed
you know to share their story and um
maybe not even to the public but maybe
to their families that
hey i have kovit because it's a stigma
within
you know the community that they'll
they'll frown upon you it's not about
being embarrassed or anything it's about
like just taking you know having enough
humility to take yourself
in and get tested around this time but
speaking out to urge the community to
take the pandemic seriously
has had a cost people referred to you as
the covid family
i mean that must be very hurtful it was
hurtful
nobody should be calling anybody names
especially for something that that uh
other families they don't have a mom and
dad anymore
you know their children passed away
because of covid
why would anybody say that when we see
now on the news footage and all the
numbers and the people that are passing
i always sit and i wonder what it you
know
why am i here you know and maybe this is
my purpose
part of my purpose is just to tell my
community about what i went through
and when you see people saying i'm not
going to wear a mask you know i
it's it's my freedom what are you having
been through what do you feel when
you see people taking that position well
i mean it's it's their freedom but it's
also our freedom to
to be healthy if we could save a life
here and there
you know i'm happy you know i will take
on
the the name callings and uh you know
the backlashes
but as long as we could inform somebody
that wasn't informed before
we'll keep you know putting our message
out there
so many families have been on this
journey they know they are the lucky
ones
one thing that this has really taught me
is that
life is super fragile and they want
their community
every community to listen
greg milam sky news los angeles